hello everyone and congratulations to
France for winning the FIFA 2018 World
Cup and while that saga is over our
Bobby Fischer saga is only beginning
this is the first video in the series
the Bobby Fischer story we're not gonna
do a series on and Bobby's entire life
as that would take us to too much too
much time rather we're just gonna cover
for this series we're just gonna cover
the 1970 palma de mallorca intra zonal
tournament the 1971 candidates matches
and 1972 World Chess Championship match
against Boris Spassky and I have already
covered some of the games that we will
be encountering in this series so when
we get to that part I will just refer
you to the link to the video I have
already created maybe maybe a year ago
but you know the game is still the same
so I don't think I'll be like making a
new video for a game I already covered
unless like it's a really special case
for some reason but in general I will
not be doing that
so as this is the first video in the
series we should discuss how Bobby even
came here in part of the mallorca to
play this inter zonal tournament and
what what was the world chess
championship cycle like in those days
well you had the zonal tournaments so
for example if you were from the United
States like Bobby Fischer was you had to
play the zonal tournament to qualify for
the Interzone all tournament in this
championship cycle the zonal tournament
was the 1969 u.s. championship and only
the top three contenders of the 1969 US
Championship were able to qualify for
the 1970 Apollo de mallorca tournament
which was the inter zonal tournament but
unfortunately for Bobby and for the
United States Bobby did not play in the
1969 United States Championship
here are the final standings of the 1969
US Championship so as you can see
tournament was won by Samuel Reshevsky
followed by Edison Banco and in four
place
fourth place you have a Lombardi so
three of the top contenders reshef ski
Addison and Banco
were able to qualify for this tournament
that we are now covering the 1970 palma
de mallorca tournament and if some of
them could make it then Lombardi would
would step in but as the United States
didn't really think that any of them had
a chance of taking the World Chess
Championship title away from the Soviets
they really really really want to Bobbie
to play now how did Bobby get here if he
didn't even play the tournament that was
meant to be a qualifier for this inter
sonal tournament well the reason Bobby
decided even though Bobby won the last
eight United States Championships he
sometimes he would lose a game or
sometimes he would lose two games in the
United States Championship and then he
thought eleven rounds in a single
championship isn't enough there should
be 22 rounds so even if you have a
mistake or if you have a bad game or you
know if you're if your form drops or
something you will still be able to
catch up and the strongest player will
definitely win the tournament after 22
rounds but as Bobby's conditions weren't
met they said that you know not everyone
is a professional chess player you know
not everyone can take a whole month of
just to play one chess tournament you
know people have other things to do
Bobby decided that he will not play this
tournament even though it's a zonal
tournament
you know required to qualify for the
Interzone all tournament now you'll
remember as I already covered the series
under nineteen fifty-nine candidates
tournament which Bobby display you know
he had a couple of very nice games but
he didn't finish all that great but in
the 1962 Bobby did crush the the intra
zonal tournament and then everyone
thought that okay he is he is in top
form
he will definitely crush the 1962
candidates tournament but not really
everyone thought it would be Bobby hood
you know and McHale bought UNIX long
reign but in the end
Bobby barely broke even in that
tournament then he you know asked for
some special special terms regarding the
1965 candidates tournament which the
organizers did agree upon but then Bobby
simply decided not to play in the 1965
candidates tournament then we had the
1960
seven inter-zonal tournament which Bobby
started playing and he was leading the
tournament but then he had a dispute
regarding some schedules of the games
with the organizers and then he decided
to leave the tournament while while
being in the lead so he already missed
the up on a lot of chances and here it's
1970 another zonal tournament which he
did not take part in and yet here he is
in the interest on all tournament of
Palma de Mallorca in 1970 so what's the
story here as we've said reshef ski
Addison and Banco qualified for the
internal tournament but banco decided to
step down so bobby fischer could take
his place in this internal tournament
but as Lombardi was like a substitute if
any reshef ski Addison or Banco couldn't
make it and then Lombardi would step in
but as Banco gave up his spot to Bobby
Fischer a Lombardi said he okay I'm not
taking your spot Bobby can play because
they all agreed Bobby was the strongest
player in the world at that time and
that he had the most chances to take
away the title from the Soviets and he
was the highest rated player in the
world so that's how Bobby came here and
you know a lot of people you know said
okay Banco was forced to do it
they paid Bank a lot of money to give up
his spot for Bobby Fischer but Banco
said no you know the United States
he said United States did so much for me
you know I did it of my own free will
you know completely voluntarily and no
one forced me into it so that's how
Bobby got his place in the 1970-71 de
mallorca inter zonal tournament and this
is a game from round one he faces German
international master okay he was
international master in 1917 1971 he
already got his Grandmaster title but
definitely a strong player as you'll see
from this game and from the results he
made in this tournament and as you know
okay we're gonna check out who who
played in this tournament who all the
participants were and you know how
everyone did and I don't have a lot of
photos from the sternum
here I found this very nice photo of
Bobby Fischer by Dragoslav and rich was
taken in the palma de mallorca I think
this is actually a photo from round one
but I could be mistaken and there aren't
all that many photos from the 1970 palma
de mallorca tournament if any of you
have like a secret stash of the 1970
palma de mallorca photos you know do
share a link in the comments so we can
all enjoy them and I will add them you
know in my future videos for this series
if not I were just gonna have to enjoy
the ones that we have so round 1 1970
palma de mallorca into the intra zonal
tournament the first game of the series
let's check it out Fischer has the white
pieces and he opens the game with E 4 we
have c6 d3 d5 and knights to d2 the
brave variation of the caro-kann defense
so I'm not going with the d4 the
standard idea but rather d3 and keeping
the position closed and I will add a
couple of more useful links in the
description below to this entire series
so whenever you're interested or you
want to check it out you know there will
be a lot of additional information
because I could really talk about it for
a long time you know Bobby's the
disputes with the wood the organizers
the letters the Bobby sent to the
organizers the letters the organizers
sent back to Bobby his replies to them
and you know a lot of very interesting
stuff that would really make this video
simply too long and all of the other
videos in this series but as usual all
of the additional content will be in the
description below so feel free to check
it out
we have g6 here Knight G to f3 Bishop to
g7 fingering the Bishop g3 first up in
Cairo his light square bishop as well
g5 now Bishop to G to 93 7
Bobby castles we have castles also rook
to e1 and here completely now closing
its d4
Bobby starts a for not allowing black to
expand on the Queen side with the b5 we
have c5 now and now comes nice to see
400 okay a for preventing black from
kicking this night away would be 5 also
now there is a double attack towards the
e5 pawn you have to defend it
and not beat the c6 nicely developing a
piece while defending the e5 pawn we
have c3 challenging blacks very strong
Center Bishop to e6 and now comes pawn
captures on d4 Huebner plays Bishop
captures on c4 we have d captures on c4
and now again he captures on d4 d5 now
by Bobby Queen to d7 and now comes h4 so
pretty much an equal position black
could be a bit better here as White's
did expand both on the Queen side and on
the King side and he's not his pieces
aren't really all that great greatly
developed to just yet we have d3 it's a
very nice pass pawn so black black
pushes it to d3 and also perhaps in the
future creates a nice square on d4 for
his Knight
we have Bishop to d2 preparing to
develop the bishop on c3 rook a to d8
and now comes Bishop to c3 now with a
triple defense of d5 pawn nice the b4
now that the pawn is on d3 a Huebner
decides that he will now play nice to be
for either forcing black forcing Bobby
to give up his bishop pair or he has to
deal with this night to see to move
somehow here what we plays Knight to d4
a very nice idea the night from d4 is
now guarding the C 2 square so nice the
c2 is not possible and of course if you
capture the Dan Bishop captures on
before will be very nice for Fischer now
Huebner will have to - double D pawns
and of course one will one will quickly
fall so what do you do here ah the best
move for well for black would would be
night night e to c6 simply getting this
night Italy into the game and now either
threatening Knight captures here or
force force Fischer to capture on c6
rather here rook F da was played and
this gave Fischer of a very nice tempo
with pawn to e6 now black has to react
to this we have pawn captures now comes
Knight captures on e6 attacking the rook
on d8 first Bishop captures on c3
attacking Bobby's rook anyone we have B
captures on c3 and
comes nice to see to as the night is no
longer on d4 guarding the C 2 square
night capture Sundy ed by Bobby
we have rook after Senate and now simply
Queen to d2 both rooks are under attack
you can't save them both so not not
really you know you can't save both of
the roofs nice captures on e1 rook
captures anyone and now King to g7 so if
you look at the position now still it's
about equal but now because black didn't
play that Knight to c6 move Bobby really
now does have the upper hand in this
position it's a better position the rook
will be a slightly more active and
although Black has a very dangerous past
d3 pawn it's not all that easy to take
advantage of this we have looked to u1
now moving the rook from the defense of
the e4 pawn but Queen captures on e4 is
impossible for a moment because rook to
e1 comes with a temple on the night
so Knight 2 g8 getting the knight back
now Queen captures on a4 is definitely a
threat but Fischer has a different idea
Bishop to d5
now the rook and Queen are no longer
guarding the past d3 pawn and Fischer
simply gives up his a 4 point for the d3
point Queen captures an a4 Fischer plays
Queen captures on d3 and now comes Luke
to e8 so it's an idea I mean the b7 pawn
is under attack but it's very hard to do
something about this if you play
something like b6 then rook to e6 will
be very active for Bobby after Queen
comes to b7 then Queen comes to e2
simply controlling this night here if
the knight have removes the rook to e7
is coming i black tries King h8 to get
out of the way Fischer would simply
improve let's say queen e3 simply
controlling the squares of this Knight
and slowly but surely white will White
will keep pushing so instead here
Huebner goes for an active idea rook to
e8 he forces a trade of rooks rope
captures an e 8 we have Queen captures
98 and now the Queen comes back into the
game and now Bishop captures on b7 so
Fischer is up a pawn here but he himself
has a double C pawn so it's not it's not
really like a real phone but you know
but but it is a pawn up
Knight to f6 Huebner reactor is the
night we have Queen to d6 and now comes
Queen to d7 offering a trade of Queen's
Queen to a6 now attacking the a7 pawn we
have Queen to f7 and now comes Queen
captures on a 7 this is a move that
perhaps came too quickly for Bobby here
Bobby had an opportunity to play Bishop
back to f3 push her back to f3 because
now blacks idea while the bishop is
still there blacks idea is to play
Knight to e4
especially if Queen captures on a 7 and
then open up and attack towards this F
to pawn which was played in the game but
which Bishop drift 3 this Bishop is
controlling tonight very nicely and
let's say after Queen to d7 black
doesn't have all that many active moves
King to g2 simply no improving the
position of the King and after the Queen
moves let's say Queen the c5 simply
improving the position for white but
okay after Queen to f7 Queen captures an
a7 was played and this allows Huebner
this well pretty much an instant draw
move and that is nice to e4 it's the
strongest move but it gives gives
nothing but a draw here
do you have to pawn is under attack you
cannot capture the night because your
Queen would be hanging so Fischer played
the only move we have f3 if you tried
something like Queen captures on c4 that
of course instead of this Knight to e4
if you tried Queen captures on c4 then
of course you lose the Queen after
Bishop to d5 but ok after Queen to a7
Knight to e4 was played DF to pawn is
under attack
f3 the only move by Fischer and now
comes Knight to d6 and now it becomes
obvious that Fischer's the bishop on b7
is a goner so there's nothing to do here
Fischer plays Queen captures on c5 we
have Knight captures attacking the Queen
and now Queen to d4 so Huebner is now up
a night but Fischer is up 3 points so if
if the knight and Queen could somehow
somehow approach the White King and then
perhaps
Fischer would be in trouble but it will
be very hard if you know the if the
Queen blocks then look
can also check on the seven pickup
tonight or the Queen would have to block
with Queen Queen back to f7 so there's
really not all that much to do here
who'd know try it King g8 we have King
to f2 and now comes Queen e7 and now
Queen to d5 check again you cannot block
with the Queen White will simply move so
came to f8 now comes h5 a Fischer wants
to completely bust those bus bus the
pawn structure so he can simply continue
checking the black king we have G
captures on h5 now comes Queen captures
on h5 and the knight to c5 who no now
tries to activate the night but official
simply plays Queen to d5 we have King to
g7 and now Queen to d4 with check again
you can't block with the Queen because
you lose the knight on c5 King moves now
comes Queen d5 check again the idea is
the same we have King moves now comes
Queen checks King moves and now Queen to
d5 you could try something like nice the
d5 but again it doesn't help you all
that much another knight is pinned the
white can simply push f4 f5 and Indian
regardless of your extra piece your king
is wide open and the white will always
be able to check you so yeah after this
Queen to d5 check once again they agree
to a draw and Bobby's first game in the
series and this palma de mallorca
inter-zonal
tournament ended in a draw so yeah and
like I said I did prepare here are these
are the final standings after de palma
de mallorca interest on all tournament
of 1970 as you all know Fischer did win
this tournament so that's not really a
surprise W but I just wanted to show you
all of the players so 24 players
participated here and as you can see
Fischer won with 18 and a half out of 23
15 wins one loss and seven rows so some
of the players as you see Bobby Fischer
in first place then bent Larsen - Geller
Robert Huebner his opponent from this
game international master Robert Hoover
with 15 out of 23
same as Geller and Larson also qualified
for the 1971 candidate matches then we
have marked
woman then Portage Smith of Pulaski
Google each panel making a hoard of Cove
ruthless miniature chefs key Mutulu
which Addison Phillip marina Whitman
Ruby Nettie and Sarah so those were the
24 players that participated in the 1970
palma de mallorca internet inter-zonal
tournament first video of this series I
do hope you enjoyed it and you know the
little prelude to this whole story and
like I said a lot of additional
information will be in the description
below are links for you to check out you
know don't don't be shy to do it and
like I said if you have some sort of a
secret stash of the 1970 palma de
mallorca inter-zonal tournament photos
do share so we can all enjoy them so I
would like to thank James Norwood for a
contribution to my channel thanks a lot
I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see soon with Game
two of this of this wonderful tournament
from from Bobby Fischer's perspective
thank you all and I'll see you soon